[Musique]
Fernanda m'a manqué, je n'avais pas ça
décédés
c'est beaucoup de mouvement vers l'avenir qui
mérite la nôtre dans le processus et s'embarquera
cette nuit la cause des éléments de vol
produits chimiques dangereux
wow ça pourrait être dangereux sans fil
cause de la canne empêchée avec l'oie
Je ne pense pas que ce sera jamais
car le procès 105 n'aura pas lieu
il n'y a que deux versions de cette histoire
ce que veut le processus qui ne veut pas
de quel côté es-tu je ne suis plus
Maison
Je préfère mourir en essayant de changer quelque chose
chose que de continuer à se cacher
michelle la chose ici
michel est un traître confirmé pour voler
le processus 105 sera le plus important
de l'histoire